this story is all about how will smith's
financial life got flipped turned upside
down
okay you see what we did there i love it
so will smith wasn't always big willie
style fresh prince style he was at one
point broke wheel style do you know this
story about will smith i don't know he
just asked me to pull it up and i'll
pull it up right now okay so will smith
we all know him if you want to show his
net worth we all know him fresh prince
of bel air bad boys men in black
independence day ali now he's playing uh
the venus and cerul serena williams
father
king oh that's right williams um
phenomenal actor man right he's worth
350 million apparently okay that's big
will stone
um but he wasn't always
chilling with the doe if you know what
i'm saying
he had his fair share of financial
issues so i don't know if you guys are
familiar with the show with this story
about will smith but we're going to talk
about it right now and what he did at
the beginning of his career what he had
to learn how to manifest greatness to
become who he was today so
you know recently will smith was
speaking in london he was being
interviewed by none other than idris
elba you know that is yeah okay and
basically goes on to tell this story
about when he was just getting started
how he borrowed 10 grand from a drug
dealer uh in west philadelphia where he
was born and raised clearly uh after he
went broke from doing what what a lot of
entrepreneurs don't do forget to pay
their taxes i don't even know if you
forgot so we'll get into that so
basically here's a business insider
story about basically
you know
let me just set the table here with will
smith so dude starts off in his teens
early 20s and he starts making music did
you this is before your day but i'm
aware can you do you remember the st the
the songs that he yeah basically one two
three philadelphia no that's not what
you want to grab you know what you want
to grammy for uh
two songs
um
to all of my kids all across the land no
need to fake it parents just don't
understand that was his first song okay
parents just don't understand one of
grammy 1989 a couple years later
[Music]
1991 nothing this is bringing zero bells
gen z get with the freaking program
will smith was killing it basically late
late 80s early 90s he wins two grammys
he comes on the scene
before he's i mean before he's the fresh
prince of bel air he's just the fresh
prince
right he wins two grammys he's killing
it he's making loot he's spending money
left and right left and right
and then all of a sudden the irs came
knocking out his door and they're like
uh yeah you owe us 2.8 million dollars
will he's like what i didn't pay taxes
yeah 100
he said they garnished his wages wait to
hear the story about will smith they
garnish his wages they start taking his
possessions so again he was being
interviewed by idris elba in london uk
and he says basically um
look quote unquote i'm not sure what the
government is like with taxes in the uk
but in the us they take that [ __ ]
seriously so uncle sam wanted his money
he's like i didn't even forget to pay i
just didn't pay straight up uh so i had
to sell everything 1990 so i can afford
to start my career and move out to la
because he knew that he needed to be out
in l.a west philadelphia born and raised
right wasn't exactly where he was going
to make his career so so basically what
he says is he borrowed quote unquote 10
grand from a friend of mine who was a
purveyor of neighborhood pharmaceuticals
aka
your friendly neighborhood drug dealer
right exactly takes 10 grand moves out
to la
boom books the gig as the french prince
of bel air this is 1990 on the spot
and he says this
get this for all our friends out there
that understand about the concept of
paying taxes and you know
the tax man uncle sam he says this
um
for the first three years of fresh
prince of bel air the irs was taking 70
of every paycheck and after the third
year i got back to zero it's terrible to
have that kind of success and have to
quietly be broke
first three years of fresh prince fresh
prince
right uncle phil out there jeffrey
carlton banks doing his thing will smith
is not making any freaking money because
he owes 2.8 million dollars to the irs
took him three years to get back to
neutral right this is what happens we
don't pay your freaking taxes you're
spending money like a drunken sailor
like you're a politician so he then goes
on to say look being famous and broke
this is a [ __ ] combination okay because
you're still famous and people recognize
you and you get all the stuff with that
but the people that recognize you while
you're sitting next to them on the bus
so you're like
that's not not so cool yeah so the the
lesson here with this and this intro
story about will smith he's become great
he's one of the greatest his kids are
amazing uh his wife awesome i mean aside
from all the issues they've had on the
sexual side of things yeah we'll get
into that
uh no matter how great you are you're
always gonna have to learn something
early on i'd rather have learn you know
early on than basically having tax
problems right now so basically this
money game ain't easy no matter who you
are you're gonna have to basically
learn the ropes uncle sam ain't no joke
we all know that here in america so
um
when you're doing your taxes when you're
making your money you gotta understand
you gotta account for uncle sam most
people pay about 20 taxes some a little
bit less some a little bit more if
you're in the 30 or something bracket
but anyone can get caught up with uncle
sam
um so he learned his lesson he's doing
his thing fresh prince boom boom boom
west philadelphia born and raised on the
playground he spent most of his days now
he's chilling in bel air and then he's
like all right cool i got back to
neutral i'm i'm starting to make money
again what's the next goal and basically
he had very lofty aspirations he says
then my next goal
is to become the biggest movie star in
the world okay
so
he basically had a plan
on how to a very strategic plan on how
to implement this you can pull up this
story dave um so he starts studying the
hollywood greats
seeing who's killing it learning from
their success who's killing it in the
box office and he sets his sight on one
person one person who was killing it in
the 90s who was that one person none
other
than tom cruise that was the man to beat
what
have they done a movie together i don't
know that'd be a sick movie sick movie
huh these days i don't know
how old you know cruz is probably 60
will smith probably in his mid 50s tom
cruise is not 60 years old how old do
you think he is uh in the 50s maybe yeah
i think he's definitely wrong go ahead
tom cruise in his 60s yeah i think he's
60 years old how old is he all right
let's look him up right now tom cruise
age somebody help us out here his age
i'm looking it up i'm looking up
tom cruise is 59 years old
i win
i win
he's not in his sixties
uh
uh july third okay so he he'll be 60 in
six months yeah baby all right you win
this one all right so basically he sets
his sight on tom cruise he starts
emulating everything about this guy
following his plan seeing what he's
doing watching his moves basically
stalking tom cruise saying i gotta beat
this guy he's monitoring his activities
watching his greatness while he's trying
to outwork him while trying to outshine
him he says whatever tom cruise is doing
i'm gonna do it for two more hours every
single day and he's watching and he's
watching him he's watching finally one
day he goes
yeah i i can't keep up with tom cruise
this guy is the has the most effort i've
ever seen in my life by far and away the
most effort in hollywood he says quote
unquote either tom seuss either tom
cruise is a cyborg or there's six of
them that's how hard tom cruise is
working so what's my point of this
i'm telling the story about will smith
starting off tax issues he gets the
hollywood fresh prince starts to make
money you know repays it back he starts
emulating the greats he focused on tom
cruise and he's like i'm just trying to
outwork tom cruise i'm gonna outwork tom
cruise and will smith as great as he is
couldn't even outwork tom cruise that's
how good he was so i love hearing these
stories about the greats the greatest
actors of our generation and and and
many scenarios right yeah leonardo
dicaprio some might say denzel some
might say
mcconaughey i don't know yeah but will
smith and tom cruise goats goats i love
hearing their stories about work ethic
because at the end of the day and we're
going to talk about work ethic in this
episode for sure a lot of stuff to cover
about four day work weeks what people
are doing implementing work week
obviously everything we've had
unemployment stimulus checks everything
like that we're gonna be talking about
the four-day workweek in a second but
when you hear
yo at the end of the day will smith put
a plan together to try to be the goat
and he tried to outwork tom cruise and
couldn't because that's how hard tom
cruise was working it makes you realize
oh [ __ ] if you want to be great one of
the greats
got to put in that work dude absolutely
yeah these guys are
different from everyone else obviously
so they're doing something that the
layman isn't so definitely a lot to
learn
i was gonna make a point about uh will
smith
but i forgot what it was let's move on
anyway he's putting in the work the
question is are you put in the work a
lot of people in america ain't trying to
put in that work what do you have to say
right no i just think it's so
interesting yeah uh a lot of people i
think especially in my generation
if my employer isn't paying my taxes i
wouldn't know and i was like working for
myself i had no idea on how to
pay my taxes well that's part of the
equation if you're an employee your
taxes are going to come out if you're a
1099 entrepreneur independent contractor
that's 100 something you need to be
aware of like will smith independent
contractor at the time right exactly
paid by record labels was an employee
tax man cometh
so
no matter where you're at in your career
you got to put in the work says will
smith if you enjoyed that short clip
from the sauce cast click here to watch
another click here to watch the full
episode or just stay bro